hi my name is ayal I'm calling from
London I hope you're enjoying the
session so far we will talk about uh
causality we know that correlation does
not imply causation but it turns out
that with some ingenious insights one
can actually reveal causal relationships
within standard observational data
without having to resort to expensive
randomized controlled trials the
objective of this talk is to explain
what that means and we'll introduce
broad topics such and we'll also Deep
dive into a few Concepts and ideas to
give you an idea about this emerging
field of causal inference that is
getting a lot of momentum
uh just before I start I want to mention
that oh I should have mentioned I am an
applied uh machine learning scientist in
uh Zimmer environment a medical
manufacturing company
um other opinions uh display today are
my own not in my employer and if you
want to follow the talk you have access
to the slides over here
um if somebody wants to put it in in in
the chat I forgot to do that
um and I actually have content worth of
maybe 45 to 60 minutes and I kind of
broke it down to like uh 25 minutes for
today uh so with that we'll begin we put
a lot of trust in data we learned today
about the importance of
um about the importance of improving
data for your AI and in that context I
always wonder are we overlooking the
question of how much trust we're putting
in data on its own what do I mean by
that what I mean is that if you take
learnings from for example from the god
Jude apparel who's considered the
Godfather of causality he talks about
the info about the fact that how we
collect information is as important of
the information itself
um another way of avoiding that is that
the story behind the data is as
important as the data itself and that
will be the main takeaway from this talk
today a few more points that you will
take away is how to avoid
misinterpretation of your data by
understanding the story behind the data
I'll introduce a very powerful tool
called graph models that that enable you
to visualize that story behind the data
such that at the end of the stock you'll
take your first steps into causal
inference this talk is for you if you
make decisions based on data and you're
interested in going beyond the standard
correlations so you can truly make
decisions based on causality there's no
prerequisites required if you know some
statistics that's great but I'm very
visual oriented in my explanations uh
just a bit about me I've been doing data
analysis for over 15 years I started my
career in astronomy and my most recent
posts are how I'll have been within the
health sector uh so the journey that
we'll take today will be climbing uh
Judah Pearl's causality ladder we're all
here mostly at the Bottom Rung which is
what's called seeing what that means
we're passive observers of our data
we're calculating correlations if we're
doing statistics or when we're doing
machine learning and we'll start off by
talking about the limitations of these
common approaches and then uh I'll
introduce a classic case of Mr
misinterpretation of data which is
called Simpsons paradox uh and by
identifying it and then solving it we're
actually climbing up to this first rung
of taking a a big active uh in order to
get uh causal causal conclusions from
our data uh I'll also introduce graph
models like I said it's a powerful tool
to visualize the story behind the data
and then we'll summarize and I'll
provide resources that I found useful
uh so we'll talk when I talk about the
limitations of correlations you'll see
in the following examples you'll see
that sometimes it will cause us to be
inconclusive we don't know what to make
out of the data or even worse we'll talk
about how it can be misleading uh so
here I'm just taking a fictional case of
a city that wants to reduce the drowning
rates at their beaches and um they're
wondering well when should we do
lifeguard Duty and you probably know the
answer to the to this problem pretty
much but let's assume you're a machine
your machine uh we're you're feeding
your machine all the city that you have
on the data and it gets excited because
it points out that there's a strong
correlation between the drowning rates
and ice cream sales so the machine
doesn't know better it can say hey we
have this uh very strong correlation
perhaps you should base drowning rates
on uh sales so is there actually
causation so we're all domain Experts of
what it means of going to the beach at
least those uh who have access to
beaches and um we know that there is a
common uh cause which is the weather
so um because you know for example that
if there is let's say there's a failure
of shipment of ice cream and there's no
sales I think that won't affect the
drownings why because that's it's impact
both of them are impacted by the weather
and so you can see when we add that
information of the weather to the data
points you can see that focusing just on
the sunny days there's no correlation
and on the chilly days also there's no
real correlation
so that's the importance of identifying
where we have spurious correlations so
this can be considered a spores
correlation because we missed a
confounding Factor the com this common
cause of course that's a very simplistic
picture real life is more nuanced uh for
example here for ice cream sales you
have to take it to account uh uh supply
and demand and here also you want to on
this side you want to account for where
we're going to put our intervention
variable where we're going to add
lifeguards
um let's go on to another example uh for
let's say that you're an engineer and
you want to improve a fire alarm well
what sort of things uh does the fire
alarm have to measure well you want to
measure the temperature of the fire it
can identify how far away it is uh where
it is in the room that's that's good too
um but actually
um is there anything else that you want
well actually
um it's a misnomer there's no such thing
as a fire alarm there smoke detections
because that's what they're actually
detecting for example if you have a
window by the fire and all the smoke
goes out the window the the alarm won't
detect the fire and so you have this
mediator variable the smoke detector
because what you actually want is it to
measure the the carbon monoxide levels I
think I'm not an expert on smoke
detectors but um yeah that's my
commentation
uh so continuing with the theme of smoke
um one of the poster trials for
causality is the the the causal link
between uh between
smoking and lung cancer which is
something that we know today and we act
upon it but in the 1950s it wasn't a
known fact and the reason is because
again they they were measuring these
correlations but they didn't truly have
a story behind the data
um one possible story at the time by the
tobacco industry was well maybe there's
a common cause That's genetics and at
the time it was the 1950s they didn't
have DNA sequencing until 50 years later
and so there's no way to resolve it if
that's what you're eliminating yourself
to uh and maybe the story is that you
know there is this sort of connection
over here but it's hard to tell which is
stronger is smoking stronger or or DNA
well how do they resolve it before uh
DNA sequencing what they realize is that
they can add immediate a mediator uh uh
variable which is you know just do this
just do x-ray scans and measure how much
tar there is on the lungs because tar is
caused by smoking not by DN not not
genetically and and then the tart causes
the lung cancer and so then you have
this causal direction and you can bypass
this and so we went from
inconclusiveness over here to something
that we can actually act on and
um and change how we approach smoking so
we talked about
um about inconclusiveness uh when you're
limiting yourself to to associative
associations and correlations but now
let's look into misinterpretations and
what we'll do now is we'll dive deep
into this uh um concept called Simpsons
Paradox and so a few disclaimers first
of all all the data used is imaginary
but it is plausible you might have this
scenario within your own data sets uh
and for Simplicity let's assume that all
the all the results are statistically
significant I have a few more
disclaimers before him uh most important
thing is that this I'm going to do
something that's probably foolish as as
a presenter and I'm going to most likely
confuse anywhere between 80 to 100 of
the audience uh but the reason I feel
that it is uh imperative is uh because
this will give you an intuition about
what causality is all about and uh
hopefully I'll break it down so it'll be
easy enough so you can kind of
understand it at least in this first
time that you hear about it or more
likely in the second or third time that
you think about this so uh let's start
and I'll dedicate 10 minutes of our time
to this because it's really worthwhile
uh so imaginary that imagine that we're
looking into a pharmacal study uh
there's a new therapeutic that's being
tested and what they do is they we have
a study of 10 000 patients that are sick
and we equally distribute them to
control that get a placebo and then
treatment would get the actual uh uh um
drugs and so the results are in and 48
of the treatment have 58 have recovered
that's noted here 72 of the control also
recovered so how well did the drug do I
subtract control from the treatment and
you get minus 14. so that suggests that
this drug is deleterious because the
control is doing slightly better than
the treatment well of course you want to
break it down to the cohorts and when
you look at that data oh sorry so and
you can visualize this with a graph
um
uh and then what you can do is you can
break it down to the cohorts you have
the males versus females and what you
see is very interesting is that you have
the exact opposite conclusion that the
drug is beneficial why because the males
have 50
recovery rate for the treatment and 40
from the recovered 50 minus 40 is 10
similar difference for for the females
90 minus 80.
um and so this is so this contradiction
the fact that we got a different result
for
um the population at Large from the
subsets from cohorts that's what's
called Simpsons Paradox and what we'll
see in the next few slides this is
actually not a contradiction but it's
rather misinterpretation because we're
missing something something essential in
in our data so here I'm just summarizing
what I said before and here I'm adding
the actual numbers here you can see 50
minus 40 that's a 10 90 minus 80 10 so
what what's what's going on this here
and one more thing we'll do we'll also
plot this we'll say here's a
contradiction here we have minus 14
deleterious effect and here we have up
here we have a positive effect both for
males and females in contradiction to
the population so how can this be and
mind that this might be even in the day
that that you have um in your own work
um so one way of of understanding this
problem one that is this plot um uh who
the idea I got from Mark Plotz who is a
data scientist that I met in pi data
Global two years ago what I said is do
the following take the control
separate it from the treatment and add
this information that we've been
ignoring so far is the number of
patients within each group I should have
marked that these this is female this is
female this is male and male and so here
you can see in the control group it's
actually 80 female and 20 uh in control
and 20 male and vice versa and the other
okay so what we were calculating before
is we were talking the mean of the
control okay that was the mean of this
group in this group so that's this red
line and in the treatment we did the
same that minus 14 is just the
difference between them
in order to understand since this
Paradox how can we have both a a
deleterious effect for the population
and beneficial for for the cohorts well
let's color code this this Visual and it
will be clear to us well when we look at
the specific co-hosts uh cohorts where
we have a a beneficial effect so which
one is it is it the um is it the
population at large that we should
consider or is it or is it the cohorts
in our case it should be the cohorts
because the gender is an independent
variable and it's not affected by if
they're in treatment or not the gender
is what it is and so we have to treat it
as confounder and what we didn't do is
we didn't control for it so that's the
solution to the problem so what that
means is that renders this approach
meaningless this is a meaningless metric
with the previous talk we talked about
what's a meaningful metric so this is a
meaningless metric and these are
meaningful okay so we have the solution
for the cohorts how do we calculate a
meaningful metric for the population uh
and the reason of course for this is
because we
um we didn't equally assign males and
females to the control and and treatment
right we had 20 percent of of the males
were in the control and what we should
have done is 50 50 does that mean we
have to go back uh to the drawing board
and collect new people in order to do
this no we can actually use a trick of a
weighted average and so that's what I'm
building up now so let's formalize uh
and build a simplistic equation uh let's
formalize the definition treatment minus
control now we'll call it a risk
difference for what we're doing we're
taking the conditional probability the
probability of recovering uh for the
treatment group minus the probability of
recovery for the control group
um so now we're formalizing that and the
reason we're doing that is in order to
calculate the effect on the population
at large we'll calculate the average
cause effect or Ace for short and what
we're doing is this weighted average so
we have the risk difference for the
males 10 for the females the same and
then we'll just plug in whatever the
ratio is between fit males or female so
that would be like let's say 50 so the
ace which is our more meaningful metric
is actually ten percent is what you'd
expect
um at large and so then we can draw this
bar that is Meaningful where again this
bar at first was meaningless uh it's oh
as I said it's okay if it completely
confused at this stage I'm the first to
admit that when I came across Simpsons
Paradox it took me a few weekends of
just sitting down playing around with
numbers and trying to figure out what's
going on so I could have that confidence
and one thing that came out of this is I
actually created uh Jupiter notebooks I
started editing widgets and eventually I
created a calculator which um you can
actually go into and try for over here
and here I'll just run it quickly by you
I really love the fact that streamlit
um can let me uh
um give access to other people to my
python code uh so here I actually coded
up exactly what I showed you in the
slides and here's like the mark plus uh
figure uh so
um so let's say
uh so let uh and what I created I did
here is I made sure all the parameters I
can uh uh uh Tinker with them and that
way I can really
live and bring exclusive products really
understand
um what happens if I change things so
let's say I take this group here of
males and I want to say that there's no
effect over here so what I do here I
take this down from 80 down to 70 and so
what you can see here this line is
aligned over here I go up here and I can
see that there's no effect for males
there is an effect for females and so
I'll give you like five seconds to think
well what would the ace be we said that
the Rd uh oh sorry just refreshed
um
I think a lot of people jumped on it so
I'll just go over here uh pictures for
five seconds what what the risk
difference would be uh so I anticipated
too many people there so here I'll just
um do it locally
um okay so this we said is meaningless
what should be the ASP so if you guessed
five percent you're totally correct
assuming uh even distribution between
males and females the average between
zero to ten percent is five percent and
so that's there's a lot of insights you
can get from playing around with this
um what I did if you go into my slides
uh we answered the first of three
questions that I post uh just to inspire
you to go and learn Simpsons Paradox
second question third question you have
the answers at the bottom of the slides
um a bit more about Simpson's Paradox uh
we could talk another way to understand
it is uh looking at its cousin Lord's
Paradox there are actually the same
thing just with different data types
since this Paradox focused on binary
data where Lords is continuous what I
mean by that by binary data in Simpsons
Paradox we dealt with
um uh um sick versus healthy uh and we
dealt with uh Placebo or the drug so
those were binary options and here we're
just in large Paradox let's say the
treatment is actually a continuous
variable let's say medicine in
milligrams and the outcome is actually
continuous and here we can see oh we
have a correlation of about let's say I
don't know between 30 to 50 percent uh
but now let's uh let's control for age
and gender and what you'll see is that
whereas the line we thought was
beneficial here we can see actually for
each age gender group it's actually
deleterious so this is a useful useful
visualization
um so
if there's one thing to take away from
these past 10 minutes about what
Simpsons Paradox is it's a situation
um it's an unfortunate situation where
the outcome of a population is in
contradiction with that of the cohorts
uh and so what why that's important it's
important because if you disregard that
you might misinter misinterpret your
data and get to the wrong conclusion so
that's a massive red flag
um how do we resolve this so so
so-called Paradox well we did that by
identifying
um uh confounding factors and
controlling for them and so
um if you really want to understand
kazali then mastering this concept of
Simpsons Paradox is your first step
I I do want to continue with this uh
with the context of controlling for
confounding factors that is essentially
most of what causality is is
understanding when you should and when
you shouldn't control for confounding
factors for example
um what's considered the golden method
of doing a causality is doing uh what I
mentioned uh in the beginning is
randomized control trials because what
you do there you eliminate from the
beginning uh confounding factors for
example in the experiment we should have
uh had equal distributions of males and
females but it's not always a possible
it might be expensive it might even some
in some situations not be ethical and
another situation might be just an
artificial setting that that doesn't
represent true life so um what we are
what we have in all of our Industries is
observational data which is much more
accessible and so what we want to do is
um if we can't do randomized control
trial well we want to understand what's
the story behind the data in order to
extract that uh causal information from
our observable observational data so
then one where's the question well
should we just control for all the
parameters well the answer to that is uh
is no we have to justify each time that
we control for one well how do we
justify this well for this you want to
introduce you want to learn a very
powerful tool called graphs models which
gives you a visual understanding of how
the parameters are related so then you
can understand when you should control
and when you shouldn't There Are Rules
it might be beyond the scope of this
talk if somebody asks in the question
section I can go over those rules but
for now I'll just introduce graph models
so this is where we are within our
agenda we've just
completed limitations of correlations in
Simpsons paradox
um so you actually know what graph
models are in the beginning when I
showed you the ice cream sales the smoke
alarm and the lung cancer are actually
used graph models without telling you
what you were looking on they're that
intuitive that you actually know what it
is but here I'll just formalize it a bit
so in a graph model each node is a
variable and if there is some sort of
association between them we draw an edge
then we can talk about directed graphs
in which not only do we have edges but
if one causes the other
then we draw an arrow of causation uh
and so uh for example here uh C is
caused by B and D and D is actually
caused by all three of them where
there's a cyclic uh um uh um formation
uh between C and D they're affecting
each other even more simple to that we
have something called Dax in which the
concept of that is for Simplicity
um
you you cannot do a run you cannot go
full circle starting when you start from
any parameter starting from a you'll
never get back to a
um so it kind of like simplifies the
problem and it's very popular within the
field to use
um
and so why why are graph model is useful
why should you consider using them well
it gives you a way to uh um
to
um it adds more vocabulary to your
statistical approach like it can explain
to yourself and others how the data was
collected and what might be the causal
relationships between the parameters
like who's which parameter is listening
to who and as a result you'll be better
at designing experiments and drawing
causal conclusions for your data uh so
actually going back to you're probably
sick of hearing about Simpsons Paradox
but actually understanding Simpsons
Paradox is much easier if you actually
consider the graph model of it so what
we have here is we mentioned that gender
is an independent variable and the group
is actually a function of gender right
we didn't equally split between them and
the outcome actually
depended on both well how do we solve
for instance Paradox well what we did is
we effectively we cut off this link over
here okay and how this one so we did
something like that we got rid of this
link how do we do that either thinking
about out in advance and doing a radical
randomized control trial but if we
didn't and we have in our observational
data what we can do that waiting average
that we talked about before the average
cost will affect the ace so that's
effectively what we're doing we're
getting rid of this link and we're
resolving for uh Simpson's Paradox so
when you draw this you'll be able to
identify Simpsons Paradox just within
your graph models which is a very
powerful thing I do it all the time in
my work
um and so
can you do can you always do causality
well that answer I think the best answer
to that is it is difficult it is
difficult it depends on many required
assumptions uh the most important is
ignorability like
you get to the conclusion that you've
probably dealt with all the unmeasured
confounding factors
um that might cause people some people
to be feel uncomfortable but there's no
way around that if you want to get the
causality or at least think that you got
to it and with that I'll summarize
um where we are and how to move forward
from here
um
so we're all at the uh most of us are at
this Bottom Rung in which we're passive
observers of the data we do correlations
and that might cause misinterpretation
like Spirits correlations or Simpsons
Paradox by resolving Simpsons Paradox we
went to the next run of doing we were
active participants in changing things
uh putting our insights our knowledge
into uh into the analysis
um
and what we were doing is uh we were
measuring results for for cohorts and
and even more powerful is this third
rung is actually doing not for like all
males at large but doing it for your for
individuals and that's through something
called counterfactuals I'll very briefly
uh mention what it what it is there was
a talk this morning on this topic it's
when you take for an individual case
like one data point and you change one
thing let's say you're you're a 35 year
old female cousin uh she went from uh
taking the placebo to taking the drug
how does that affect her in particular
uh the main What's called the
fundamental problem in causality is you
cannot do that in real life but if you
have a scenario in which you know which
direction it goes what the result to
expect if you do that splitting in
approach uh in changing of one of those
features like did they take the drug or
not
um then you can get to uh on counter
factuals and learn things per individual
level
um so that brings us to applicability
can you also because I'll let okay well
not always you're most likely to be able
to if you have a simulated or fully
controlled environment uh for example
like machine simulations you'll be able
to do that but real world data
um is more likely to be messy and you
won't be able to do that
um but my Approach is know what your
limits are like
analyze your situation and um try to
evaluate the applicability based on the
tools that I've described
um like graph models uh and by doing so
you'll be better at designing
experiments and analyzing your results
just further motivation uh the Nobel
Prize for uh um in economics last year
went to economists who actually applied
causal inference in the field of
Education of Education
um
and uh yeah so should we put Oliver
chest just in the data alone so bring us
not only the data but also the story
behind it the reason for that is the
story behind the data is as important as
the data itself because
um it's important to understand how the
data was collected so we can understand
the relationships between them and by
doing so we'll be able to understand the
causal relationships between the
parameters
um so I'll just summarize and then I'll
uh provide resources that I find useful
on this topic we talked about
misinterpretation of data by
understanding by by understand the story
behind the data we'll be able to avoid
misinterpretation we talked about
squares correlations Simpsons Paradox we
talked about graph tools as an awesome
graph models is an awesome tool to
visualize a story story behind the data
so we can understand causal
relationships I didn't talk about but in
my slides you learn about justifying
controlling for confounding variables
when you should when you shouldn't and
then if you're interested in taking the
next steps well first of all master
Simpson's Paradox by all means use the
the calculator that I posted and there
are other topics that I didn't talk
about today do Algebra I mentioned
briefly counterfactuals
um just before the resources uh a
massive shout out to the doodle James
Barker the doodle Master himself who uh
was kind enough to uh to to create these
beautiful visuals
um to to to explain this this topic
um I created in my previous uh row I've
created a study group in which we
actually learned this book and I found
it's very useful and everything I
explained where uh lessons from this
book a more Layman approach is this one
by Judah Pearl as well these other books
were recommended by colleagues of mine
um if you're interested in doing an
online course I can't think one that is
better than Brady Niels
um which is free it explains very well
the concepts very slow very patient and
very uh stimulating
um if you want to draw that's
um excuse the blasphemy yeah I I I I
might have to interrupt you there I
think there is a wealth of resources
that you could probably share and
perhaps give more information in in
Discord if you if you don't mind
there is probably one minute to field
one question if that's all right with
you yeah yeah sure
all right um there was a uh uh quite a
lot of it I will pick one of them
because it seems quite definitive
there we go the creation of cosmographs
is Arcane to me how do you actually
prove the direction of the relation uh
do you do an evaluation between models
and how can you improve you do not have
an augmented variable perhaps a short
answer there could be quite useful
Emiliano that that's thank you for that
I mean that's an excellent question
um so I'll answer
um like I'll Identify two means first of
all
um yes anything that we do in statistics
as was mentioned in the previous talk um
there is an element of subjectivity
um like how do you when you have a
distribution how do you know if to quote
the mean the the median maybe there's
two modes maybe you want to understand
um why you have two modes so in that
sense yes there's going to be
subjectivity the nice thing about graph
models is yes you're I'm going to apply
your subjective opinion but there are uh
mathematical ways to test uh um the
relation the directions and the
relationships for example if there if
you draw an edge between the two well
first you can calculate is there a
correlation between them if there's no
correlation then most likely there is uh
there's not going to be an edge between
them that's a bit over simplistic what I
said uh but when you get into learning
about graph models you learn about
something called Forks and inverted
forks and those are a way of looking at
the direction and then you can by using
a conditional probabilities
um those are way to test different part
you can to segment your graph into
smaller parts like those triangles that
I showed before you can break them off
in order to test your assumptions so
there are ways to test your assumptions
nothing's bulletproof but there are ways
to
um to do uh a few tests to test your
assumptions but that's an excellent
question